i'm a spokesperson said that kakuenza
ruchira bashaija says this is the price
he paid for criticizing uganda's ruling
family he says his ordeal began in
december when soldiers broke into his
house beat him tied him and blindfolded
him before driving him to a military
barracks i don't know what they were
using to beat me in the back either
hippopotamus whip or
a wire
something that really
gets
into the skin it was very painful
excruciating pain
he was detained for four weeks he says
he saw and heard several other prisoners
being tortured too including one man
whose skin was repeatedly burned with an
iron he says the interrogations were
brutal getting
a pliers they start plucking flesh from
my thighs all of this
he believes he was arrested because of
the two books he's published the first
was a satirical critique of uganda's
president yuri museveni and he says he
was detained and tortured for it two
years ago
he described what happened in the second
book the ugandan government denies
running torture chambers this matter is
being investigated by government
within the security circles
but it's not true for him to say
that people who are detained in uganda
are tortured
it is not true to say that there is no
freedom of speech in uganda
president museveni has ruled uganda for
36 years his regime has faced growing
accusations of rights abuses
it's his son general mohozie kainarugaba
that kukuenza blames for his detention
and torture mahouzy denies it and says
he's never met kacuenza
bukakuenza says mahosi saw him three
times during his detention
forced him to apologize made threats and
offered him money to take his books
offline and stop writing that is when i
met
general mahouzy for the third time
and he was like
he wanted to be sure
whether if i am released i am not going
to write another book about my torture
cacuenza was taken to court last month
and charged with insulting the ruling
family the court kept his passport but
he fled to germany where he says he
plans to write another book documenting
what happened to him they have the money
they have the guns but
they touch the wrong battle
they joke with the power of a pain
he says he's so traumatized he can
barely sleep for more than an hour
before being woken by nightmares
he says he'll seek medical treatment in
germany but plans to return to uganda
and continue writing
malcolm webb al jazeera